stephen king loves stranger things but
he's got one big complaint about the
latest season what's king's beef with
the duffer brothers latest keep watching
to find out
warning stranger things season 4
spoilers ahead
it's been three long years since fans
last saw some stranger things but the
show's highly anticipated fourth season
is finally here for all to enjoy the
show hasn't missed a beat picking up
with the same level of horror and
intrigue that's gone on to define the
series
as such it perhaps should come as no
surprise to hear that one of the series
most ardent fans is the king of horror
himself stephen king
indeed the show owes a debt to king and
his impressive body of work especially
when it comes to season 4. the series
has always maintained strong roots to
king's work especially seeing how the
series is set in a sleepy small town
which has often been the setting of
king's stories and in the most recent
season there's a clear homage to king's
carry when 11 has a chocolate milkshake
thrown all over her which parallels to
the pig blood scene and carry while king
seems to love the series he does have
one complaint that appears to be shared
by other fans i mean like less like so
many other fans have done king has taken
to social media to voice his opinion on
the most recent stranger things season
while he seems primarily smitten with
the latest batch of episodes he does
have one point he'd like to make king
posted to twitter
the new season of stranger things is
really cool as good or better than the
previous three there's even a carry rep
is it the whole season or is it another
one of those that's broken into two
parts in my humble opinion that's kind
of lame
stranger things season 4 has indeed been
split into two volumes the first
collection came out on may 27th while
the second part is slated to release on
july 1st the second volume will only
consist of the final two episodes the
last of which will clock in at a
staggering two hours and 30 minutes on
twitter plenty of other people have
voiced their frustration with having to
wait for more stranger things with one
fan posting whoever decided to split
season 4 of stranger things into two
parts needs to be put in jail
immediately
immediately
seriously
another fan wrote
ugh why didn't i know that stranger
things last season was being broken into
two parts i would have waited before i
binged it patience is a virtue and all
of us including masters of horror will
just have to wait another month until we
know what happens between the kids from
hawkins and vecna no doubt about it
netflix has truly changed the game when
it comes to release strategies for the
most part entire shows of seasons are
dropped on the platform all at once for
people to binge watch
lately the streamers begun experimenting
with dual volumes which was the case
with the final season of ozark and now
it's doing the same thing with stranger
things season 4 where the first seven
episodes came out initially followed by
the final two on july 1st even the
length of the episodes each one
basically being a feature-length movie
is unique in the current television
landscape season 4 of stranger things is
ambitious in scope in more ways than one
and according to executive producer sean
levy there is a very good reason why
this dual release strategy was
implemented even if it was to the
chagrin of stephen king
as levy explained to the hollywood
reporter
we didn't think nine episodes were going
to be ready in time and we have made the
world wait long enough we always knew
that if we could deliver the first seven
it's such a satisfying breaking point
and payoff moment that it will keep
people fed enough for weeks so we can
finish up volume two it sounds like the
desire to divide season 4 was born from
necessity and allowed the team behind
the series to get more time to ensure
those final two episodes were as good as
possible levy went on to discuss how
streaming allowed the team to play
around with the release model saying
every streamer is playing around with
different models we've seen full season
binge-worthy streaming aka stranger
things one two and three we've seen
disney plus and hulu try a weekly model
which didn't feel quite right for this
so we're happy that we're able to give
our audience a huge meal of a story
anyone who's finished episode 7 of
stranger things season 4 is undoubtedly
waiting on pins and needles to see how
everything wraps up and hopefully the
team manages to stick that landing and
avoid the wrath of the king of horror i
didn't like the ending
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
stranger things are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
you